這裡是AI101,全網最幽默的AI新聞。
Cruzo退掉了Boom Supersonic超過12.5億美元的大單,
一共29臺發電渦輪機。
Cruzo可是Boom最關鍵的客戶。
這筆單為什麼這麼要緊?
Boom的算盤是先賣地上發電機,
再用營收和獲利造天上飛機,
也就是Overture超音速客機。
這筆訂單未來若帶來持續營收與獲利,
本來就是要養超音速客機的。
回頭看Boom的飛機。
2025年1月,XB-1驗證機突破音障,
最高1.05馬赫
可是XB1用的是三聚線程的機翼
引擎不是自己造的
那Boom自己的引擎呢
原本共同研究推進系統的
Rose Royce在2022年退出
Boom後來改為主導開發Symphony
客機跟引擎兩條線都得繼續推
兩樣都花大錢
錢從哪來
執行長Blake Shaw自述
他曾傳訊問早期投資人Sam Altman
電力是不是AI的主要限制
Altman回答是
既然缺電
Boom就以同一套引擎核心為基礎
做成地面發電用的天然氣渦輪機
SuperPower
單機輸出4200萬瓦
跟Symphony約8成硬體共用
賣給AI資料中心
時間回到2025年12月
Boom拿下Cruzo這張大單
2026年2月又先訂了31具發電機
現在大單沒有了
這批發電機要去哪兒
還沒有公開答案
話說回來
燃氣發電設備是真的缺
大廠基於Venova的訂單和產能預留
從2025年底的83GW
漲到2026年第二季的116GW
且已開始接受2031年交付時段的預留
可是反差在這
Cruzo沒有放棄渦輪機
早就向GE、Venova定了接近一級瓦
它不是不懂天然氣發電
也不是突然不要電
偏偏退了
那會不會是Cruzo缺錢
9月17日
Cruzo才宣佈F輪完成初次交割
整輪預計規模39億美元
8天后
SHOE就在X上宣佈雙方不再合作
推出Superpower
不缺錢
那為什麼退
雙方各說各話
TechCrunch報道
Shaw貼文裡原本寫的原因被刪了
Cruso發言人則向TechCrunch表示
能源計劃沒變
人會用渦輪機
只是不是boom的
真正原因都沒公開
比起分手原因
工程進度更敏感
9月初發布的工廠參訪影片顯示
首顆引擎核心還在最後組裝
後面要點火
連接發電機
跑滿載耐久測試
抵整機測試還有一段路
組裝都還沒有完成
boom仍然喊出
2027年交付約250IW
2028年拉到一級瓦
可是新客戶是誰
BOOM
一個都沒有公佈
所以下一關就是點火
首顆核心能不能在2026年底前
完成首次運轉測試
2027年底能不能交出第一批Superpower
兩項事業壓同一顆核心
成功一起開路
延後一起賠掉信用
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息